hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inscription sorry
for the long delay also i was just
sitting here before i got recording and
this little thing popped up
i don't know what that was about i'm not
100 sure
also i don't exactly remember what i was
doing
i know i was doing something okay so i
don't know why that popped up and i
don't know why there was a save to it
but i can't get on that so
i think it had something to do with the
beast dude the dude that was a part of
this and yes this is inscription if you
didn't see the last episode this isn't
going to make a lot of sense to you
like
things have changed
dagnabbit i can smell that meat on you
and i'm still missing that dang hound
can't you put a little in her bowl
i didn't realize i had meat
[Music]
oh hi
oh
uh
okay
hi
well
i'll be down
that's my girl
i'll let you pass me and in the
underpond dagnab at first we got a
battle
oh
well darn it all
your deck ain't right
get you at least 20 cards in it
uh
oh aha
i need to build my deck
interesting well i'm going to
rely on the old reliable
uh mantis god oh you're ruling this guy
that thing
bloodhound this that
uh waterborne one it provides an energy
cell to its owner that sounds good
all right
what does this do generate one bone oh
good but i don't really have a lot of
bone thing i don't know any of this leap
bot
automaton
i don't know
oh weird i don't understand well i need
to find more
cards anyway
so i'm gonna go find more cards i guess
this is weird
no lie this is weird what is this place
you're here
marvelous i am grimora scribe of the
dead
until quite recently i was disgraced
though i was returned to my former glory
with the help of some
unlikely friends if you wish to test
your skills against me you must first
prove your wits
you must discern which two marks the
final resting places of my lovely ghouls
okay
you found a piece of an epitaph that
reads eaten by a hungry dog
okay
you found a piece of an epitaph
it reads does not hold a grudge
okay
hi
[Music]
bruh did someone leave the ac on oh come
on dude it's freezing in here maybe a
heated battle will help
oh something's wrong it's your deck
rather lack of a valid one you've got 20
cards in it right
no
no i don't
hi
[Music]
you wish to trade
i don't know i don't know man
i don't know man
dude i don't know man
everything's different from what i
remember
i don't remember none of this
okay
weird
i
oh no no do not look upon me
do not snarl sniff i beg you if you wish
to battle please let's get it over with
okay so i can't battle any of these
dudes because i don't have the car yards
all right so i gotta go find more cards
there's got to be another pack lying
around here somewhere
right
that's got to be the deal
ah whatever you won't let me pass
where do i get more cards
i mean i guess technically speaking
no
get out of there if mage people's owner
controls no mox cards made people
perishes what is a mox
oh i see interesting
cannot be sacrificed
i'll do
because i remember about magnificus
being important i guess
oh right
wait a minute hang on i picked magic
didn't i
that's what i picked
so i have to figure out what this magic
stuff does
aha blue mage has played draw quartz
equivalent to the number amount of mox
cards on the side of the board
okay
all right so now i have
magic so since i picked magic that's
what i have so that's what i'm gonna go
with bear with me this is all new to me
so i need to figure this out hi
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
gonna battle you oh yeah
what is this
okay
greetings my consciousness has been
summoned it seems but for what purpose
ah you've selected my starter deck and
require a short lesson you see magical
cards are powered by mocks though some
refer to them as gems if you have one of
these mox cards on the board you may
play cards with that cox [ __ ]
start by playing one
alright i played one you see
now you may play magical cards of that
gems color it is quite simple really i
cannot comprehend how my students
sometimes struggle but i have digressed
carry on i await you atop my tower
so i can play this dude blue mage draws
on the power of your gems
and i can play this dude because i have
a mox
you draw
oh i drew cards
just like that i should have played the
other ones first
um no amount of mox cards okay i didn't
have
it's fine
i'm learning here whoa what is that i
don't know what that does
okay
take
that okay
go for it
ow
hold on there buddy hold on
so if i
were to say
can i
oh
goodbye
all right but if i put a mox card there
just to chuck it
to two cards leaps over to block don't
matter
it don't matter none okay
let me just go for that
i'm doing one point at a time i only
need one more point of damage to be done
so pretty easy huh
done
i win
it's a weird low-res version of the game
that i was playing before but it's still
the game okay fair's fair you beat me
like a dog take this someday these your
cards are better than gold
i received a beastly card back okay
interesting a stim mage pay three energy
to increase the power and health of a
stim mage i'm not gonna know how all
these collaborate
all right give em all
these cards were added to your
collection thank you the way the
underpond is clear
i'm assuming i needed something here for
the fisherman oh
[Music]
found that what is that
place the photo of bait on this
yeah let's do it
that's a whoa
got you
[Music]
i guess you weren't going anywhere so
it's totally fine
but whatever
what an odd game
fish fresh fish good
still must beat
all right i'll beat you
i think
i hope
i'm not 100 sure salmon at the end of
the owner's turn salmon will move in the
direction described all right can do put
you there put you there done i think all
this is just guesswork for now don't
don't get on my case if it's bad
i'm trying my best here
i'll get it done
you go there
bam bam
easy
easy done
you beat
you pass
first take
another beastly card back thank you i
could make a beastly thing now but i
think i'm okay green mage equal to the
number of green gems that the owner has
on their side of the table i can only
place so many so
cards were added
i'll work out how to the details later
me or continue
find fish for leshi
all right thanks bud whoa
is that a trap
i think that's a trap i probably
shouldn't touch that
yoink oh i touched it good thing i did
i'm guessing the thing is i need to trap
this bunny
patches of dried blood crackled as you
pried okay
why was there dried blood on that chest
i'll take him thank you
oh another one
thank you
oh you missed it
dude you missed it buddy pal friend come
on oh
oh i
got him
thank you all right i did it i'm the
best i got myself a pelt
i think i take this to the trader but
let me see what this guy wanted first
i see you have a photo of a pelt the
traitor next door may desire it
all right
can do why is there blood on your bed
why is your bed bloody
hmm there's a faint odor where the meat
once was it's a fridge it's not a bed it
looks like a bed all right okay good
good good hi
you brought a pelt i'm pleased yet
another turn of the skinning knife it's
time to set another trap oh
oh god
i smell the hair's blood on you
okay this is a little
unnecessary
oh
burrowing trap can't be sacrificed when
an empty space would be struck burrowing
trap will move to that space to receive
the strike instead also when burrowing
trap perishes the creature opposing it
perishes as well a pelt is created in
your hand all right well i'm gonna do a
little bit of magic here by going schwam
schwamm
and i know that it's gonna die but its
purpose will be served once i draw these
cards
you guys don't do nothing do you medusum
moving around
bam
i did it i think
ow
so i don't have much in the way of
damaging cards to be perfectly honest
i should have beast cards because i can
sacrifice these dudes i should uh once i
get killed here i'm guessing
i can redo my deck a bit and hopefully
hopefully i'll be able to do something a
little better
i know
bam
sure
you go there i'm gonna get rid of this
you go there bam
oh you took both of those hits well
that's unfortunate for me
um well oops i haven't been doing this
quite as well as i thought i should
oh boy
i don't have any cards that actually do
damage i can't even do anything with you
either
oh well oh this is bad
that's bad
well
can't do nothing
all right
oops yeesh
ow
come closer you'll make a fine belt oh
well good it's not game over okay so
what i need to do is i need to i can do
it right here i don't need to go
anywhere let's give me a moment i'm
gonna think about this and try to
coordinate something that's gonna work
well with a specific style because this
the blue mage is cool in terms of being
able to draw let's just trash this for
now draw more cards which i always like
i always like that so i'm thinking i do
that
with
three of those dudes to match and then
add some of these dudes in for sacrifice
and just a little bit of damage so i've
got mocks i've got blue mages i got mage
pupils
and then the rest
i lean on squirrel ball at the end of
filmer's turn squirrel ball will move in
the direction inscribed and drop a
squirrel card in their oil space
i love that that's great and then i'm
gonna add some of these cards in i'm not
gonna worry about the energy just yet
i'm trying to get synergy first between
the magic and these cards okay field
mice when field mice is played a copy of
it is created in your hand that's great
i like that
um salmon nah
let's do the wolf cubs i love the
squirrel ball mantis is good
the uh you really would be great but i
don't have anything that can generate
enough blood to be able to get it
so i'm going to leave it
i should probably get some of these and
then i'll just get more bullfrogs
and just do more bullfrogs and one of
these oh actually this guy would be
pretty good
mole man okay
done
let's try that that's a bit better
that's a bit of a better one
all right hey pal let's uh let's you and
me talk why don't you and me when we
have a conversation i need to
need to mask you something who love this
okay interesting
coordination
uh sacrifice
put you there
and then
leave that for now
yes
wham wham wham
wham ow
well it lived its usefulness and that's
all that really matters okay first off
i'm gonna put mole man no i can't
because i can't put mole man down unless
i were to sacrifice this dude from old
man
that's
better i gotta remember how to play this
game
i've kind of completely forgotten
blue mage draws on the yes
that's what we'd like to see
i'ma get rid of you
and i'm gonna put
this dude
right where he is because he can't be
hit back
but he'll turn into a wolf i guess then
he'll just die but hopefully maybe i
could sacrifice him before he dies
and that'll help me
okay i'm gonna take a point from this
old man digs down nope he's a hero he's
a hero and i've transcended
yes
yes okay so what i need to do is i need
to put you down and then i guess i could
have just left him out for a second but
that's fine
yeah let's just leave it at this for now
okay that's dead that's not dead
good good good okay so here's what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna
do nothing it's hard without those
initial squirrels and bees i i really
don't have a lot to sacrifice
i gotta think about this a little better
you're dead unfortunately
ow
thank you old man your sacrifice is not
in vain
okay well this is a problem because i
can't even
do that
okay interesting all right so i've
almost pretty much just lost this again
because i don't have any way
of getting what i need out without those
abilities of like killing things again
and getting more cards i'm not thinking
properly about that
as opposed to like the right strategy of
of going forward with other things also
i i don't like magic as much as i
thought i might nothing to do i think
i'm just lost
well way to go buddy all right i guess
oh
there we go
damn
okay it's fine it's fine i'm i'm working
on it i'm working on it so what went
wrong squirrel ball i really needed
squirrel ball up in there so blue mage
was decent but without the right carts
to draw i kind of just fell on my face i
mean these are good just because they
are my sacrificial lamb they're
basically the only thing i have to
sacrifice and it was unfortunate that i
got all three of my sapphire mocks right
off the get-go oh i can have more than
20. oh well that's convenient
i might as well just put them all in i
guess so what else could i do i've got
all my one costs besides this thing
provides a battery which could allow me
to get these things which are
sacrificable
put them in why not let's see what
happens more things to sacrifice at
least more things to summon in general
at least
okay
we've got
[Music]
a u
and then
you
got one of these things but i can't put
that down yet but i got these out
some initial damage which has been what
i've been doing but it's not enough
ah that's not quite as much as i would
like it to be i got these three dudes
out
first for some reason i forgot to
shuffle my deck
interesting
thanks guys thank you
all right i've got this thing which
would allow me to summon that bot
which is interesting weird what does
this do when a creature moves into the
space opposing the century dome there
developed one damage yeah
interesting so let me
kill this put this here
move this there
i bet it doesn't happen it has to move
in front of it i see i see i see
i see it has to move i got i'm learning
i'm learning squirrel ball huh
not very helpful
i guess it would put down squirrels but
then i'd lose out whatever screw it i i
want to see it work hey look at that no
don't kill it oh well that was
short-lived
all right
i guess
here we go
oh it's gonna die in an instant
i don't have anything to sacrifice that
that trap sucks
oh
man this sucks i just get i just end up
having nothing i gotta do better
i gotta do something better i could do
bone cost things hey let me start over
hang on this is taking some
muscle to think about i do think this is
a good strategy those are good because
they are literally the only thing that
can keep me actually going in the fight
which is what i need but i need to think
about things that'll die bones and
whatnot
let's put these in
because without them i basically have
nothing let's put in all my one cost
things and nothing else because there's
no way that i'm going to be able to kill
more than just the one i'm not going to
get the sentry turret or any of these
because i don't have enough energy
generation to even worry about that and
the card draw thing if there's only ever
one card on the field that's a power i
might as well just not have it in my
deck because i would draw it
so it's useless
i think
let's try this
i got it i got it hold on
all right what do we have
absolutely nothing we can do great we
started off with a hand that we can do
absolutely nothing
oh my god
oh there we go thank you
oh i start out with three energy cells
wait
wait you start off with energy
i didn't know that you start with energy
and let me just try what i did again
because i got totally hosed on my
starting hand okay here we go
this is marginally better there's no
point in putting the wolf cub out
because it's just gonna die immediately
oh i get one every turn
interesting
i don't need this mox
[Music]
okay
i'm back i'm backing off i'm backing off
i'm gonna go try to fight an easier
opponent because i need to build up the
deck that i have
magic was a bad choice i'm gonna go to
the crypt because i can go here and uh
these guys wanted to be fought so i'm
gonna fight them i think my hand sucks
but it is what it is and i should be
able to beat someone
like you i was better off just doing
like the basic magic stuff i don't know
why i was doing anything else anyway
all right let's see what i can do
nothing god damn it i
hate this hand i oh god i oh god
oh
okay doing the hybrid right now is not
working out for me so i'm not even gonna
bother i'm not even gonna bother i'm not
even gonna bother i'm not even gonna
bother i'm just gonna go straight up
magic and that's it and i'm not even
gonna bother with anything else okay i'm
just gonna go green and blue
and that's it all right let's try this
because at least i should be able to do
something with my life at least i should
be able to do something okay
okay
okay i can put both of these down and i
can put you there and you there
look at this i'm making things happen
shockingly
let's just keep it up
oh
okay well this is not helpful
great
okay this is not helpful great
oh there goes my moxie
ah at least i have this
yes it's
what hang on what is this thing after
attacking skeleton parishes uh whatever
i just need to block this damage until i
get something actually worthwhile
no
collapses into a pile yeah
oh my god
can i get
one card too late huh
oh good
i can't play
you this
i'm grumpled i'm grumpled guys i am
grumpled
i'm i'm gonna win
so it does work in
overtime i guess
die
you finish it oh my god
i did it excess damage foils gained oh i
get foil packs if i do excess damage
holy crap it's over you shoot me out
now please look away turn your eyes to
this card pack instead
received a deathly card back
i see
i see good great
i'm called sawyer the middle stone marks
my grave please
do not go in digging up my bones
you found a piece of an epitaph sawyer
patel 1702 fall
1778.
um oh i do not sniff or snarl whatever i
guess i i guess the thing i got wasn't a
foil oh card back
i didn't know that was a card back i
would open that sooner if this is what i
needed i needed to get more cards
hark oh god i skipped that
bright intrigue is a lime
you think you'll squeeze the defeat out
of me
i think maybe i don't know it's hard to
tell with this deck it's hard to tell
all right get ready to get juiced
i'm gonna be freaking juiced bro
you just played a card with an activated
ability alas i shall explain to you its
workings activate it by pressing the
sigil like it's a button but it'll only
work if you can pay the cost well i
can't so i won't
take that
all right
what is that oh no i didn't know that
did that oh well i'm doomed
or am i
mayhaps i'm not
[Music]
wow
okay not really what i was thinking but
let's juice him up
stim mates grow stronger good
shoot him up
just pump them full
all right so far so good
only one more
never mind it's two
[Music]
oh my god it's fine
oh i could have stemmed them up i didn't
even notice that
oh i get that every turn okay so it's
like it regenerates
ah i could have i could have boosted him
a bit more
interesting well i can no longer put
this guy out which is dumb but whatever
okay but on the next one i should win
i should win
boost
and boost wow that's actually pretty
good i didn't know that power just was
there the whole time
yes
i like foils whatever they is i like
them
and whatever they get me i'm gonna like
them okay now the magic deck is making
more sense i needed to get used to it
and everything's fine i you beat the
pulp out of me
firstly take you this
uh-huh
i'm not gonna use that deck i'll use
something in it cars were added to your
collection okay and because you bested
me with you
i'll share my secret
my name's royal nice far right tomb
here's a headpiece
i found an epitaph royal dominguez 1587
spring 1632
like i said
life didn't give me lemons so i
what did you say are wants to find his
pirates on the seas
look at me now buried under the far
right tomb
okay cool found a piece of an epitaph
hit by a falling piece of ice oh that
guy
found a card pack
it's too easy to accidentally skip
things 13 bones oh my god
that's expensive
hello
found a piece of an epitaph there was no
cure
hi
oh god
what did i do
oh
i like this one
all right so my appearance changed
that's cool
i'm fine with that
huh
found a piece of an epitaph brought down
by scurvy
gust of foul smelling air billows from
the casket oh
hi
you have no offering
okay all right bye
forever
goodbye and forever
uh
a bird someone leave the ac on oh cause
that's ice in your head right okay cool
good
good good good good
good good good good good okay what are
we doing here what is this strawger
can't be sacrificed when drucker
perishes the creature inside it's
released in its place oh well i'll just
match you up with that forever okay you
fly which means that whatever is there
anyway doesn't
matter but i can hit it still
i'll put you there and then this guy's
gonna get on the juice
soon
maybe i played him too soon if i can't
get him on the juice
because i can't quite get them on the
juice yet
[Music]
take that oh
all right
not the most helpful
why did you draw two cards then
the amount of mox cards totally doesn't
have to be blue
die
live this is not proper distribution of
cards this is six of 21 cards that i
have that i've drawn
all right i didn't juice him why didn't
i do some i meant to juice them up
i meant to juice them last time i didn't
juice them let's see
you go there
you're gonna go there
okay cool
that's going to release something when
it goes
just the wimpiest things
this is the absolute wimpiest things but
i think i've won
so it works
it works it does work this this this
deck does work
you won
but now i'm a bit less cold take a pack
on the house
well thank you thank you very much
you did beat me so i guess i've got to
fess up the name's
casey casey hopps
i'm from the tombstone on the left
casey obvious 1970 to winter 1992. ah
pulled out an epideve piece the
defibrillator failed okay i get you i
understand
i understand
you wish to trade
oh you have the foils i see
i see well i don't want any foils from
you i want to get them from either the
magic person wherever they are
okay
i see okay casey ops was on the left bam
uh hit by a piece of falling ice the
defibrillator failed
done
easy
this is
sawyer patel
nope eaten by a hungry dog probably
doesn't hold a grudge this was royal
dominguez
brought down by scurvy there was no cure
got it marvelous i believe you have
proven your wits adequately are you
prepared you will not defeat me
i didn't know i was battling you
marvelous just marvelous i was beginning
to worry i would be sealed away behind
those tombstones forever
locked down at the mercy of a
challenger's wits until one day
discovered but no you prevailed and now
it's time to battle all right let's see
oh wow
well this is one of oh this is a special
one my minions never truly die you know
let's see how are you fair
all right that was
mean and creepy why would you say that
why would you say that
would you say that to me
oh they're dancing
[Music]
they're dancing
i love that
all right uh well since pushy mc mc
pusher sins over here i'm not gonna
worry about him too much
yeah go go pick on the mage pupil he
deserves it
oh i love that i love that i love that
i love that what is that sarcophagus
will grow into more powerful form after
one turn on the board
well i can't do much about that so
take that looks like i'm gonna win this
round though
which is nice
hey
take this
why does that say plus oh marvelous an
opportunity to use my quill rip bone
hound turn one to turn three death by
mage pupil this one will be back
okay
why though
but but why though you're halfway there
though you may not like what comes next
ah
what
well that was mean
do you miss them fear not i'll give them
back of course
as corpses
well that's mean why would you do that
[Music]
what good does this do me well i guess
i'll put them back because corpses they
can't do much but i can't do anything
else anyway so
this might as well soak up some damage i
guess
i wish i could sacrifice him but i don't
have any b stuff no matter death is
never final
zombie turn four to turn five definitely
made people that one won't be back in no
time
sarcophagus transcends to a higher form
oh god
well that's not good that's not good at
all
let's try to get some damage on the
board i guess
uh what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna put
this guy here and that to block that but
fat lot of good that's gonna do
oh i've got no chance
there's no way
this is no way
oh muscle mage moves to a new space
pushing why do you oh well actually
thank you that that helped out
incredibly
although i seem to be taking a lot more
damage
oh [ __ ] okay well that's it for me
okay
well i didn't want to fight a boss
anyway so whatever
i don't would shut up and go away i'm
leaving and screw you
i didn't want to be here anyway you and
your stupid death cards it's a bunch of
baloney
i shouldn't have picked the deck that i
couldn't build up until i get to this
area which is just unfortunate let me go
see if i can defeat this goddamn pelt
trader hey
shut up whenever i walk up to someone
that i know i just tell them to shut up
right away really puts them in their
place
yeah
all right
if i could just stop getting so many
goddamn resource cards off the bat i
would be so happy
i would be so happy
and this would be great if and only i i
do
muscle mage stim mage sorry
i know i could block but i don't know
what well i should have
oh this is just so little done
oh i didn't beef them god i forget every
time
all right beef up but what does it
matter
or i'm gonna trash that
oh wait no god why did i do that
oh my god
why did i do that
i don't know
uh
[Music]
god this is gonna die
that's the thing it's just gonna die
like right away it's gonna die
i guess i should have
i should have oh
god damn it i should have used this guy
to hit that guy would it have hit first
i don't think it would have i don't
think it would have anyway well i can't
do jack [ __ ] god
i miss my cards i missed the fly no you
ruley did i get any more of these what
are you i paid two bones to whoa
gourmage
ah
i didn't get anything much of anything
else useful but at least i have some
things what if i just have two of these
because it seems like i always have too
many of those
and another muscle man sure come at me
bro
see so i only have two of each of these
in my deck i get one of each which is
great don't get me wrong
i like that that's cool whatever it's
fine all right
[Music]
all right
doesn't make any sense
[Music]
that did work out for me now like oh i
don't have a green that's right god damn
it okay better kill that thing then
oh man this is just
oh
okay well i'm making progress but that
thing flies right over it so what does
that matter i have a lot of i don't have
a green
[Music]
i think he's out
yes no i don't have a green god okay
it's fine
now i can make some progress okay can i
please summon some good cards like a
i should have put one of these down
whatever it's fine i basically won
what happened to my greens i before i
couldn't stop getting those things but
now i can't get them anymore
okay i'm gonna put this down and i know
this is weird but i really want to get
some overkill so i can get a foil
i'm out of cards
oh god
i didn't know that was a thing
okay i guess i i guess i just lost my
green is that that's what happened okay
anyway ow
why would you do that
whoa
no no no no i win i win i win i win
the trap is shot yet the prey escapes
and the trapper waits for the next
victim you've defeated the three of us
now unless she awaits
okay beastly card back thanks
thank you
oh pharaoh's pets pharaoh's pets is
counted as three blood rather than one
blood one sacrifice also when powers
froze pet is sacrificed it does not
perish
that's lovely that's like that goat nice
nice thanks thanks pal can you please
help me
trade uh oh
oh look at this look at this nonsense
look at this this is great i've only got
five foil though because i wasn't able
to do a lot of overkill
should i get a pack the aura boris is
there it's just as strong as i left it
oh it's just as strong as i left it oh
god i want it i want it i want it i want
it
i want it
i'm sorry
just gotta wait i need to just get more
cards
[Music]
hey
this is looking good and the pharaoh's
pad i got two of those now i've only had
enough bones to deal with it
okay
i'm trashing this look at these rares i
got look at these look at these lovely
things the electricity is probably cool
meatbot is counted as three blood one
sacrifice instead of just one
huh
let me go back to
what i was doing before with this
i'm kind of curious
let's try this i i'm just screwing
around with stuff i don't know if i'm
doing good or doing very bad
let's try you bested the unhinged
prospect the gormless angler and the
enigmatic trapper you found yourself
standing before your ultimate match
leshi scribe of the beasts steal
yourself for my beasts will show you no
mercy
only fangs ah hey you said you weren't
gonna do that anymore do not spare your
creatures my camera is waiting to
capture them at the moment of their
demise
and my beasts are finished okay well
you're a weirdo
all right this is one more dude
yeah
take some of that
silly
looks like i'm gonna win
oh
i'm sorry i wish i didn't put that there
it'll have to do oh you think you're up
uh i don't want to put that there
actually at all
but i do want to do this
take some of that
i'm probably going to lose these cards
aren't i we never did finish your death
card there wasn't enough death
i hope you don't mind my filling in the
blanks
oh hi
okay that's interesting it's a squirrel
cat i see what it is now okay well it's
also very useless
all right let's go with it i guess yeah
mole man's about to do the shuffle
okay wow that's a bear all right ow
okay i can't do
anything
oh god
okay that's finally dead but
[Music]
i was doing so good
i'm just gonna go in again i know it's
not a great deck i'm still figuring it
out people it had a completely different
game for so long and then suddenly it's
gonna throw this at me i can't do
anything with this
my bone person there i would love to
keep but you know you're not gonna let
me are you
i guess i die
a little that mole i don't like looking
at that now i guess i die
it's okay i'm just gonna go again i'm
just gonna go again i'm just gonna go
again
that's the same
hand all right fine i'm gonna put things
out but only so that i can kill it and
get
moleman out here
i guess
[Music]
great
no
don't kill moleman
uh
don't do it mormon oh
why why why
why what are the odds of this
could i please go to another area i
would love to go somewhere else can i go
somewhere else i would love to go to see
the other people
wolf it's hard to get back in the swings
gotta gather that momentum
oh you know what you're more right than
you think
hi what do you what is this
what's that about
pick the clover leaf from the stem why
hey what's up man sometimes i try this
spot find good fish corrupted fish old
fish
okay
vote scribe only in case bad happen
back up playing unless you say
i catch old fish last time good fish
beat dredger eat goo eat casey good fish
unless you trust are not disappoint
okay sure whatever you say man i don't
even know what you're talking about but
i got a clover so that's a thing
i guess
all right
looks like i got to do this the hard way
and by the hard way that just means get
a better deck what about some of this
energy nonsense i seem to always get
energy no matter what it can do like no
damage though
kind of useless
maybe i should do a magic death deck you
know maybe that's what i need to do i
got some good death cards let's uh put
them in
when another creature you own dies it is
returned to life and then dies again
immediately
okay
sure when dead hand is played discard
your hand then draw a new hand of four
cards
i like that headless horseman i'll never
get enough bones for that but i like
these skeletons that cost nothing that's
nice
see once broken opal is struck the
striker has dealt a single point of
damage that's nice
free flyers that's good mummy lord is
cool let's add some more of these dudes
in there
got my sapphire mox in there let's try
that i think magic bone might be the way
to go come here leshi i'm gonna kick
your ass this is the one
oh yeah what is this
oh interesting i didn't want to do that
but good to know that i could do that
now i'm kind of screwed
but okay can you go there
i'll just eat that
ah yeah
and bone's gone
cost is nothing dude
okay
god damn it
i didn't know that's what the clover did
or else i wouldn't have done it
god this
is killing me
legitimately killing me i feel i'm
i'm dying
this is killing me
i should have put that i don't know what
i was thinking i'm not thinking right
[Music]
okay this is at least this is lasting
longer than i thought it would
um
however it's not doing me
wonders
[Music]
is that all it does it just raises it to
die once more i guess because it
generates another bone or something like
that i guess
i guess yeah you know that's what it do
interesting
okay please tell me he's just completely
run out of cards and even his second
phase won't have anything
[Music]
right
oh god what is that you must like them
though the stitch work is my own they're
your cards these cards suck why would
you do this why would you do this
why would you do this i guess it's fine
i'll just feed him there because they're
they're just gonna be fodder for the
grizzly
well thanks for the bones where's all my
bone cards seriously where are all my
bone cards
where are my bone cards
don't i have more bone cards than this
there we go that's a bone card all right
that's a bone card
god i wish i could play this
oh no another bear i thought oh brother
bear
okay
i think i can beef it up enough
will it work
i think it'll kill this first and then i
get to wham them
i just wham them right
no
yes yes yes
[Applause]
oh
god yeah yeah
yeah
the great scribe was incredibly bested
far away the light enveloped the long
forgotten monument
yeah the monument being your ass is
grass
and eat mine
[ __ ]
you had triumphed narrowly avoiding
tooth and claw
the scribe of beast was defeated that
you were able to defeat me beggar's
belief but now i must yield to you
my only regret is that our battle was so
brief surely the summit of victory is
made sweeter by a more arduous ascent
all right one pack
thanks buddy thanks pal
thank you pal
oh another one
oh yeah the cat
hell yeah
god yes okay that's great i love that
i love that
battery low what the hell does that mean
i saw that squirrel
the scribe of beast was defeated
okay fine whatever stop what is that
whoa hi
[Music]
i had to see your face after you lost
you're just so
bad it's no wonder we're back here again
and we would have been even sooner if
the disc wasn't lost
take a long look at this face because
you'll never see it again
i'm done being your pet your stinking
beast
that guy was the ferret in case you
couldn't tell
i pushed it too far that last time
why don't they see
to live as a beast would be the noblest
thing
even so lowly his creature is a stone
stoat not affair
all right whatever you say buddy
whatever you see
all right bye
i gotta go spend my foils
oh
you know what i don't want us
well i could do squirrel though
i wouldn't mind having squirrel because
that could start me off on my journey
although i don't have my unlimited
squirrel draw as i did before i gotta
make do of everything else all this new
rebalancing is just a pain in my dick
i'll figure it out later so that's all
the time i have for this episode thank
you everybody so much for watching we're
getting back into this game and i'm
getting my legs under me with my my
playing i should be able to clear out
all the other bosses in next episode
because now that i'm getting the hang of
it i'm gonna in the off screen futz with
the deck a bit and see if i can figure
something out so thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]